I did a series was run viral and then
the eyes are on you
[Music]
it was the three one of three of the
most viral Trends and it obviously
boosted my profile a huge amount you
know it's open doors to do books get big
investors in the restaurant look at
other sites already be full I mean
there's obviously negatives to anything
every article that ever came out it was
like oh Tick Tock star yeah I just found
a bit derogatory considering Works in
restaurants my whole career I grew up in
in the countryside in herefordshire you
know we keep pigs and sheep and chickens
and so I grew up understanding food from
a very young age
the restaurant's called Strikers I don't
know how I came up with that name we
wanted to create a restaurant that was
you know neighborhood first and foremost
with good energy relaxed Vibe but
serious good food great music
comfortable seats and I was confident in
the fact that we could create a
successful restaurant we haven't really
compromised on the quality of the
ingredients we've got longer seeing
scallops we had turbo on but we had to
take it off because it's 50 Quid a kilo
at the moment all of the mollusks are
like mussels and clams and stuff like
that are pretty inexpensive so we've got
a flat bread with muscle butter and that
is absolutely delicious probably one of
the best sellers anything with flour and
water is a winner the restaurant we've
got a few of the appliances on gas which
is obviously quite expensive we've been
got a charcoal grill and a wood fired
pizza oven less expensive and those big
big items hold residual heat all night
so you'll come in the morning the pizza
oven's still at 250 degrees and I think
there's pressure for me to like you know
critics want to be in to criticize
because I've got a profile and they're
like let's see you on this buttered guy
can do I don't want to get pigeonholed
into doing something I think before the
content was much more natural there was
more food that you could cook at home
you know I'd just go back to being
me
[Music]